citizens of the reject nation we are
here today to watch house
of the dragon i'm very excited for this
i've heard really great things about
this show i'm waiting to tell john this
on camera did you know matt smith is
actually a massive fan of our channel
yeah are you messing with me right now
yeah totally messing around
damn it i was so hoping that would be
true
matt if you're out there leaving
comments never heard of it let me go you
really have me going for a half a second
there anyway
guys leave a like
i got my gamer throwing pants on hey
which is a sign that i'm i'm a massive
massive massive knowledgeable
encyclopedia walking around it's easy to
own a shirt but when you've got it on
your nethers that means you're true i'm
not flaunting now and also subscribe and
click that notification bell to get
notified when our reaction for the next
episode of house of the dragon is up
just a solid warning uh youtube's been
really strict lately so if there's any
specific kind of content might have to
be uh communicated out of here in
whatever way we can think of you know
what i mean following three action watch
alongs where you sync up with the time
code i mean your own copy available over
for our super sexy rejects our patreon
page cover a bunch of shows exclusively
over there with reaction highlights and
watch songs included and the team at
prepper thank you for editing down what
i can only assume is easy to do yeah
in a short amount of time fishing enough
to get up on youtube alright let's get
to it
[Music]
a woman
would not inherit the iron throne can't
have a woman do that duh
saint westerwoke
jiharis called the great council to
prevent a war being fought over his
succession
for he knew the cold truth
hearing the theme
who are those people
diner it's clear guys this is 172 years
before game of thrones
you got all that to look forward to
it's a bird it's a plane
it's a
dragons
you're doing great hiccups
[Music]
a little tiny saddle on top
wowie
this has a game of thrones season eight
budget money
look guys we're gonna make up for it i
promise
spared no expense no there's a lot of
wide shots here yeah
big sets
lots of extras
you
will lie in this bed soon enough for an
error this discomfort is how we serve
the realm
i'd rather serve as a knight and ride to
battle and glory the child bed is our
battlefield
there's more
do you think damon is distracted by his
present tasks and that his thoughts and
energies are occupied well one would
hope so considering the associated costs
then let us all consider your gold well
invested lord bees breed hey man he's
having fun killing and bonin
before the games are over my son will be
born we have no way of predicting the
sex of the child of course none based is
capable of rendering an opinion free of
conditions are they now there's a boy in
the queen's belly
i know it
i've invented sonograms
damn old school iron throne
[Music]
so slimy already
i brought you something
sounds way nicer in his actual voice i
know
way less sinister
now
you know it
no queen on my watch
can you say yet what it is
i've sent inquiries to the citadel they
are searching the text for similar cases
it's a small cut from sitting the throne
it's nothing yeah whose sword you cut it
on yeah
it looks [ __ ] beautiful
nothing will cause the babe to grow it
does not already possess one
this child is a boy ever
i've never been more certain of anything
i dream of his testicles
this is the last time
nope you're gonna keep going
i know it is my duty to provide you an
hour
and i'm sorry if i have failed you in
that i am
but i've mourned all the dead children
just let damon have the throne yeah he's
already got a penis
he looks like he'd have a great time
doing it
my brother's city has fallen into
squalor
no longer
beginning tonight king's landing will
learn to fear the color gold
what are they gonna do i'm just gonna go
out in the middle of the night and
slaughter people i guess
it's gonna go occupy by force
[Music]
did the king approve of this
[Music]
oh he doesn't even know he's in town
yeah he doesn't know anything about this
but he's gonna be really happy once he
finds out
oh
i mean you know i thought in the video
but you know what just happened yeah
i still have to process
bring out your dad
your brother made a public show of it
meeting out the summary judgments
himself
until they needed a two-horse car
to haul away the resulting
dismemberments when it was done
that's it i'm not raising my incest baby
our city should be safe for all its
people i agree
i just hope you don't have to maim half
of my city to achieve this
time will tell
oh he's sick
he's so good dude
you made a vow before the seven to honor
your wife in marriage give lady rare to
you lord hightower your own lady wife
passed recently oh my god what an ass
you know how my brother makes sport of
provoking you
must you indulge him
yeah this is your fault
get it together
this council has at great expense better
the city watch to your exacting
standards
enforce my laws but understand
any further performances like last
night's will be answered
[Laughter]
damon's wife is going to be eva mendes
from the other guys
inexplicably hot
you see the sheep great day
has been made more auspicious
by the news
that i am happy to share
queen emma has begun her labors
and as we all know it will be a boy for
sure princess rainey is targaryen
i would humbly ask for the favor of the
queen who never was oh
what are you playing at
good fortunes you cousin i would gladly
take it if i thought i needed it
[Applause]
you're about to die
what a shot
[Applause]
prince of the city will now choose
[Applause]
god
that armor
like a devil helmet yeah
straight off the morbius
said this is my vampire
[Applause]
high
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh she the daughter of otto i think so
correct us if we're wrong
[Applause]
oh he's gonna do something shady isn't
he uh he's just getting riled up
whoa
oh is that a loud no i
guess so
why doesn't everyone do that
oh no oh he's done [ __ ] he's facing
dustin
surprised the horse isn't more jacked up
now i'm fairly certain i can win these
games lady allison
having your favor would all but assure
it
oh my god is she attracted to him i'm
afraid she might be
he's so cruel what he's doing
oh man
i love it i love him
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you let her slip a ring around a phallic
object like that the infant is in breach
your grace all attempts to turn the
vapor fails
[Applause]
full of steel and balls full of seed and
we expect them to act with honor and
grace
it's a marvel that war didn't break out
of first blood
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i'm in the wrong show poor guy
[Music]
a technique is taught at the citadel
which involves cutting directly into the
womb to free the infant you can save the
child
we must either act now
or leave it with the gods
let's go proto c-section
i mean they're both going to die so just
a very thought of you having to make the
choice yourself though
although you can still see his eyes a
little bit
[Music]
she has no idea what's about to happen i
don't think she does
oh it's all right
what does that mean
i do not like this
[Laughter]
nice oh that's not going well
that's that is horrifying
[Music]
oh my god that is so horrifying
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
false yield
i was hoping to ask for the princess's
favor
somebody demons just sneak up there
congratulations your grace
you have a son oh
and you and your grace
damon is not going to be thrilled
oh [ __ ] you gotta be [ __ ] me oh i
thought the baby was about to die i know
i'm not waiting for it to happen still
like if the baby doesn't die itself he's
just gonna challenge it to a joust or
something
[Music]
that was really disturbing yeah that was
the harshest that was harsher that was
than any of the jousting or anything
like that yeah that was one of the
hardest things
game of thrones
in general yeah
damn that was harsh that was really
harsh oh you just feel every slice you
know you just feel all that pain and
fear
yeah
oh
it did the baby did die you gotta be
[ __ ] me oh wow
[Music]
oh man
she's never felt good enough for him
[Music]
dude that guy was on cloud9
oh [ __ ]
that i was like oh he's going to die
right now
that's so that is
wow what a first episode yeah that of
your succession
these recent tragedies have left you
without an obvious heir the king has an
heir my lord has despite how difficult
this time is your grace i feel it
empty see this
if the gods should visit some further
tragedy on you either by design or
accident
what are you saying
my brother would murder me take my crown
i mean yeah
damon has ambition yes but not for the
throne
he lacks the patience for it
the gods have yet to make a man who
lacks the patience for absolute power
your grace
that's a great point who else would have
a claim
the daughter yet
say it king's first born child reynesis
was the only child of joharis eldest son
she had a strong claim at the great
council and she already has a major just
moments ago you announced your support
for david we cannot agree on an air then
how can we explain our son are dead i
know you heartless pastors yes jesus
how is his grace very low
which is why i suffered
i thought you might go to him
or for him comfort
in his chambers
no
you know you might wear one of your
mother's dresses ah i was liking you i
know
you're doing so well
i was like nice to have one of the good
ones oh my god he's awful
so gamers runs like cedudia
what is it allison
i thought i might come and look in on
you grace
i brought a book
it's very kind thank you
wow
that is a hobby you did that tonight yep
this is amazing how productive you are
when you're grieving
when my mother
died people only ever spoke to me in
riddles all i wanted was for someone to
say that they were sorry for what
happened to me
i'm very sorry your grace
he toasted prince balon to the king's
son
styling him
the heir for a day
ten years you've been king and yet not
once have you asked me to be your hand
why would i do that because i'm your
brother if i see otto heiter for what he
is
an unwavering and loyal hand
wow jeez inherit nothing he doesn't
seize for himself otto hightower is a
more honorable man than you could ever
be i don't know about that i have
decided to name a new heir
i'm your hair not anymore
oh [ __ ] you are to return to runestone
and your lady wife at once
and you are to do so without quarrel
[Music]
[Music]
it's a great little metaphor motif
cool looks like a xenomorph
from that angle queen alien one that
brought valeria it's doom if we don't
mind our own histories it will do the
same to us
targaryen must understand this to be
king
or queen
your brother can't be queen
what are you saying
wanting for a son
oh [ __ ] is he going to announce it he's
going to turn her into a son
damon is your heart
damon was not made to wear the crown oh
my gosh but i believe that you were
callis of house velaryon
lord of the tides
dude
you just put a target on her back
promise to be faithful to king viserys
and his named heir the princess renee
i pledge fully to them
and shall defend them against all
enemies in good faith
and without deceit oh she knows she
knows what she's in for
this is no trivial gesture
dragon saddle is one thing
but the iron throne is the most
dangerous seat in the realm look at how
many cuts i have
swords
and voice of old town promised to be
faithful to king viserys
and his named heir the princess rhaenyra
oh look at her damn she
can't tell she's for it or pissed yeah
i better be both
our histories
they tell us that egon looked across the
blackwater from dragonstone saw a rich
land right for the capture
egg on foresaw the end of the world of
men
just to begin with a terrible winter
absolute darkness riding on those winds
and whatever dwells within will destroy
the world of the living damn talking
about
them and then stark and if the world
have managed to survive a targaryen must
be seated on the iron throne
there's an irony to unite the realm
against the cold and the dark
egon called his dream the song of ice
and fire hey hey cool
manira targaryen
princess of dragonstone
and heir
to the iron throne
[Music]
all right that was uh
that was heavy it was heavy
heavy dock
great scotch
it was
they i was like all right
setup episode let's go
day
one
reintroduction
so i was not expecting
anything like
that violent
yeah i wasn't her i wasn't expecting
like the full prologue
yeah and while there's like no that's
like a bunch of
it's a decent amount more there's a lot
more action than i was expecting for a
first episode yeah i mean from the
jousting alone a lot more violence in
fact in some ways there's there's more
violence than there is action yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah cause it's not
necessarily like an ongoing battle so
much it's just a lot of people get
slaughtered at different points yeah
i liked you a lot i thought it was a
really great first episode yeah
solid it's very intimate and personal
and uh
yeah it was like when they're starting
off with all the political talk
okay get it custom getting acquainted
here's where we are with targaryens at
this point in time all right i got it i
got it i got it this real simple story
of
again who's gonna see it the iron throne
but it's not like hopping around like to
a bunch of different locations or
whatever it's all focused very much so
on king's landing
and over the course of just a couple of
days really yeah
and this very immediate moment in
conflict of who's going to be announced
to be heir to the throne it's a really
like
simple to latch onto concept
and having the familiarity of game of
thrones you get the fun easter eggs and
all the houses and stuff like that and
it's just part of the world
uh but what they
built here with the characters it it
does create this sense of uh
of fear
of oh my god what's this damon guy gonna
do because i don't know the outcome yeah
like
i i don't in terms of
who dies i mean obviously they're they
all eventually
but uh but like how deaths are going to
occur who to really trust likes what
becomes of rhaenyra like
is that pronounced her name ranira
renera i i think rainier i know
um what becomes a rhaenyra in terms of
that does she get slaughtered does she
die yeah are they gonna fake this out
right now because they think that she's
gonna be the big character she's gonna
kill her next episode where does she
fake her death and then get away yeah
you know like how does she escape this
situation
because it it does sort of feel like the
rise of the mad king in the bloodline of
targaryens yeah yeah absolutely it feels
like that like i don't know what the
actual outcome is for there's a lot to
not know it's like yeah okay we all know
what happens in game of thrones and that
story of um
of a
song of ice and fire
that would've just yeah yeah okay i was
like
that's the first only question like the
song of fire no that's why this is
firing blood it's a pretty fire blood
yeah
yeah
um so yeah like having i i i think the
the thing that with the good prequels
that's that's what they have to have you
do is while they're talking about things
especially in the ending moment of
guys this is important to give the roots
yeah
this is going to lead to the white
walkers
we first saw the white walkers
targaryen on the thrones the only way to
save you know everybody for mass
destruction yeah so i i i i like
yeah
but even without having to tie it into
the future of what we know of what's to
come
i
i like these characters quite a bit
you know like matt smith
i think elevates anything he's in i
liked him in morbius
despite the fact no one seems to really
like morbius
you didn't buy the collector's edition
dvd he's my favorite doctor we've had so
far i've seen so far i think he would
share the same sentiment i think yeah
um last night in soho he's awesome i did
not know damon was going to be a villain
or at least that much of a villain yeah
i mean
no i didn't i just had no idea
his name is damon and he's [ __ ] a
walking heavy metal cover i know
there's always a lightning bolt striking
behind
a girl strapped to his
holding onto his leg as he does a wicked
guitar solo on dragon back yeah this is
a game of thrones world so they could do
something we're like oh now i really
care about this guy well i saw it uh
that's the thing is is
at least in the trailer yeah i got the
vibe of like okay he's gonna be the more
cutthroat the more like vicious
character at least that's the vibe i get
but in this episode even though he very
much lives up to that there is that
moment where they're at the funeral pyre
and when he's talking to
ranira like i actually bought that
moment of like you got to be here for
your dad like you know this is this is a
really tough time he's going through
yeah and as conniving as he is and as
much as you know i'm sure he's at that
moment
string pulling or or you know conniving
to some degree it felt like a real
moment and that moment made me go okay i
am anticipating now the moments further
on in the to the show where yeah they
make him feel more human or like that
reversal with hightower with otto uh
where it's like that nothing icky came
of that but it's still i feel like the
suggestion is intentional we know that
we know of yes and i feel like part of
me was wondering
was otto trying to get his daughter
pregnant to make her have that i know i
know
yeah to take his mind off the tragedy of
his family by giving him a new
opportunity for a male heir because
rainer is just air yes yeah you know
yeah
so
they can denounce that
um
wow that's crazy yeah that's really
crazy so
uh on imdb you got
two rain arrows listed
yeah
is one like a younger is there gonna be
a flashback or something like that or do
we
is one the mom
no it's emma right uh
[Music]
that's a great way yeah what is it
because yeah that's the other thing too
is is in game of thrones and i'm sure
anybody who's read the book is probably
sitting there going it's not that hard
you just gotta commit it to memory
but like so many of the names do get
similar and and as they would in like a
family lineage where the whole point is
to make everybody remember the lineage
so yeah
uh uh right now it says she's listen
they said two rain arrows are listed in
10 episodes we had the imdb pulled up in
front of us yeah
name reference
um
i don't know that's bizarre
maybe she's just credited
can you do a flash forward could it be
just spoil some heavy [ __ ] first of
what's going on here it makes me wonder
because i mean at least looking at this
page everyone's listed for 10 episodes
and that makes me
wonder two things one you know like if
it's your main cast oftentimes even if
they're not in an episode if it's the
season that they're in they'll get
credit but
this is like they have the same name and
and one is that we've been hanging out
with it's specifically listed as young
so maybe there's going to be a a time
time jump imminent yeah i don't know if
they're trying to throw us off on imdb
because you know that can be a spoiler
when you see like oh this character is
only listed for four episodes so they're
either gonna leave or die and that's one
thing that i am very curious about with
this show because game of thrones i
think one of the biggest pieces of the
game of thrones reputation as a book and
as a piece of television was that yeah
you never know who is safe who's gonna
die it's a cutthroat world that will not
give you what is just dramatically
satisfying off the bat and i wonder if
this show is going to do that as much
well what i really like about this
because
with getting a refresher on some history
with the targaryens
um
you know like the path that they carved
out for themselves with
having a premonition and then fleeing
valyria
having dragonstone then and then which
now they have king's landing
so having the premonitions or the the
foresight or whatever this
i don't see i don't run these dreams i
haven't seen um
i haven't seen game of thrones since it
aired
yeah so i don't know
i don't recall daenerys having she had
like dreams that that became true i
think so i feel like she there's a dream
element yes yeah i think i think so yeah
yeah but but having uh
sorry guys
we are not the go-to experts we are your
your average audience member we will
have all the books read by next week
yeah um
so yeah but with having uh with having
the qualities of these characters i
totally forgot what where my train of
thought was going where were we at uh we
were trying to figure out if de niro's
had uh
visions or dreams time travel back
conversation where were we let's see
different is there going to be a time
jump four hours of sleep john help my
brain out i was doing great up until
five minutes ago help me out help me out
uh is this gonna be the kind of game of
thrones world where they you know like
kill a lot of people
targaryen history you could do it uh it
doesn't matter i'll think about dragon
stone now they got kings landing uh yeah
uh
uh nope don't have it
it'll it'll come back to you yeah the
way it intertwines with what may come in
the future and that's i don't know like
part of me oh what i was saying wait i i
got it i i forgot how i was gonna take
those points and bring it to this point
but i got my point here we are
is
you know when watching game of thrones
they always made something like uh
[ __ ] if they only didn't have that
mad king targaryens would be in power
yeah yeah they want to have all this uh
terrible loss or the position right like
it always seemed like it was linked to
that which it is um however you're we're
watching here because they've carved
this path and they've become dominant
and they they're literally like the
[ __ ] rulers
of everything and
this is this the start of when the shift
began began with the targaryens of not
following tradition
have uh announcing on the daughter to be
heir yeah instead trying to embrace the
queen and you could feel the discomfort
in the room with everyone so i really
like this plot setup it's more
interesting than me then let's do a mad
king show yeah i like i like this setup
of oh there was something much more
pivotal before that
that started the targaryens down a
questionable path and you know it's like
you have
uh damon who's like look brother they
don't
they don't fear us they don't respect us
really like yeah we're not as cool as we
should we ought to be perceived as they
just take advantage of you for their own
gain yeah and then you know you have all
there's always a difference of
philosophies but then you have uh
rhaenyra who clearly doesn't give a [ __ ]
about this
doesn't want this but also doesn't have
the station to be like no yeah and damon
craves power yeah um but he would be uh
a of
a tyrant
leader a bad kid yeah he would be a mad
king
and then it seems like when you got
people like otto hightower who are very
friendly and and
and whatever
they're you could still see there's
perhaps a conniving quality you know
and even with the sister who didn't get
announced it's like oh this is where the
plotting against it seems like there was
a lot of respect for the targaryens and
their legacy yeah but here is where
the the stabbings and the back and all
that started occurring starting like
that's interesting like i think that's
really interesting because it always
just sounded to me
that once they got to mad king that's
when the [ __ ] went downhill
yeah but there had to be yeah some chain
reaction that gets us there yeah starts
the downward spiral yeah yeah yeah and
that yeah that does seem like a
fascinating place to go and a way to i
mean i know it's based on novels so it's
all there but you know just like if
you're just a show viewer coming out of
game of thrones it's like oh pretty cool
they could do anything yeah no exactly
but this feels like a natural extension
of that lore without having to bend over
backwards like you know if you've only
seen the show this feels like a natural
part of that story to shine a light on
and explore and that will then enrich
what's coming in the future and that
makes it not feel so like mickey mousey
when they're like and eventually you
know like
from the north there's going to come
white walkers and stuff you know like
that actually feels more appropriate
than just like game of thrones you know
in in a setting like this and with the
context that is here yeah and so yeah
it's like you are
you know 175 200 years in the past but
it doesn't feel quite so distant as that
sounds
just when you hear that number
and i think that's you know it still
feels like that's the thing coming back
to game of thrones coming into a new
series like i've had my cynicism is just
based on how the show the original run
of game of thrones ended but this
at least as an outset at least as a
setting of all the table it did feel
like you mentioned the big production
value like it really feels like you're
there in the world and it feels like
they are still very much concerned with
the political
and the sordid emotional aspects just as
much as everything else
i i think it's a great set like
it's way more to me than mad king and
like young daenerys right now yeah oh
god no
yeah yeah i mean we've already done
young daenerys uh but this seems uh
like uh
because the trailer sort of hinted at a
potential civil war and i l and i love
them like not knowing
you know what's to happen
how the fates of these characters unfold
yeah i i i really i really like being in
that position and i like that it's just
targaryen focus i'm sure we'll get the
explore the other houses as things
progress and stuff oh yeah but there's
something that again the word that keeps
coming to mind is intimate there's
something that feels very intimate um
well yeah this journey i mean it it they
use that sense of intimacy to enhance
most everything and especially like that
whole birthing scene is
so horrible because of how intimate it
like you're right there for like the
most anguished final moments of this
woman's life like it's it's yeah it's
really striking the way that they're
able to do that to have like the big
crazy production spectacle but maintain
that focus it makes it all hurt that
much more yeah that was truly disturbing
that was awful yeah like that was you
come back to the battlefield and you're
like i could watch th this is fine man
smash a dude's face in but yeah like
this this
this it's just such a cruel cold scary
sad end to that character like i felt so
bad for her
and i mean you know viserys is a
relatively sympathetic character but
even in that moment you're like oh my
god like
the math
and like he's the one who's like guys my
wife and son just died but even then in
the moment when they're in the birthing
room you can tell those wheels are
spinning like
but i could save my air though you know
well i think what they did that they
painted out really well
is
the optics around viserys is
he's not
he might be overly compassionate and an
overly sensitive king
and then you have damon
who's too unhinged
right that's that's the perception
yet i think we got scenes of both of
those characters that don't feel like
that's their only note yeah like you
have scenes of damon where you do see us
a bit of a softer side you have scenes
of damon where in his quieter moments he
looks
conflicted about this path that he's on
he's not mustache twirling you know yeah
uh like he made a good like that scene
whether he's arguing with his brother is
really solid and then viserys you could
feel
the the the ruling hand of a king in
that moment so i i think that um the way
that the actors have done it because
like when you look at game of thrones
you know the only thing that pilot won
the first episode one time but it's like
an ugly world but here's the best family
in that ugly world here's the starks get
on board and here's the lannisters this
is the [ __ ] disgusting
yeah
but here you know you're just
you're in the muck of of what you know
is kind of a
messy procedure
[Music]
um
you know like
and that like uh that coldness to to
watching the violence unfold like
everyone in the crowd just a reaction
channel
oh yeah i mean that's what we liked back
then and it's funny
i liked to the way that they handled
both of those sequences with between
yeah the tournament but also
the um you know when he takes the city
guard in and and he's i like the way
they unfold that because at first you're
like
it's so immediate that it almost throws
you to be like they're slaughtering
these people it's so cruel and then you
start to realize how they're
slaughtering them suggests what their
crimes were
and it's just like so gut-wrenching in
that moment and and and yeah that you
realize that like it's a thin line
between what violence people in this
world deem horrific versus what they
deem as entertainment and oftentimes the
act is almost the same yeah it's just a
thousand percent yeah it's just about
you know oh well you know the king drew
us together to celebrate today so this
is great violence and we love it
and uh and yeah like it uh
without
yeah it's that grayness like you said
it's it's even the common folk have an
aspect of that sort of bloodlust within
them that seems to
really
affect
every part of this world
yeah they managed to make drugs and that
feels very personal uh-huh you know
are they trying to head to rene or an
area as
i couldn't tell if they were like okay
they're just
different they're just close friends you
know with girls you can you can just be
super close friends landon each other's
lap i get that oh but also like what is
there a bit of something more here
because i can't be
i can't tell that's too much i don't
want a sun show i don't want a son i
want to just love my alice or whatever
her name is alison al ali kent ah so
what's your name should be on this
freaking thing
allison sounds right yeah allison
heights hour there you go
there you go
i don't know i mean i could see it i
could imagine it happening
uh it's because you know as much as you
know game of thrones is is well known i
think among you know readers and fans
for having you know like a pretty good
grip on making
characters whatever their gender or
background just real characters but uh
you know i don't know if people would be
able to handle that in this day and age
you know everybody gets freaked out
about wokeness and stuff and it's
already like we're arguing about can a
queen take the throne if she was a
lesbian too man i think people would
explode who knows but i'm for it let's
do it and also risa fonz who i'm so used
to playing
like sleazy or a villain or just
somebody off-putting and unsettling yeah
i was watching him here and i was like
you know it's nice to see him play
someone who's uh doesn't really have the
most power but yeah you know he's like a
good guy he's good he's doing what he
can in a harsh world he's a good dude
yeah yeah
but oh no reese of fonz of course that's
what they don't
yeah
creepiness lurking just beneath the
surface
sleazy guy if it's just real world
you're just a sleazy guy
or you know
yeah
yeah or if it's a heightened world then
you're like an outlandish amoral
whatever character yeah yeah all right
guys well house of the dragon what did
you all think
leave your thoughts down below
hey let's end this with a patron
mark leach
my buddy um
we talked a little bit i got to follow
up with you again some more
i don't want to talk too much about what
you've been uh having to deal with as of
late that's
your decision what to talk about so i i
just wanted to say though
that
for everything we've do and i mean this
sincerely from everything that we have
discussed um
about personal lives prior to the
experiences that you've had recently
you've always displayed being an ins
like a
really sympathetic and empathetic
nurturing uh individual
a sensitive individual too with a with a
very
shining sense of humor as well
so i'm i'm sorry for
what you've had to deal with
as of late
and i'm hoping that right now you're
surrounded by tons of
love and support
and as easy as it can be for people to
just say you know it gets easier with
time it does
and
i also wanted to say that
the most important messages to you but
the most important thing you can do in
situations like this
is
really just feel your feelings be honest
with yourself
even when you're having a hard time
feeling your feelings even if you just
want to escape you know so
just
really
you know like
don't be afraid or if you are afraid
just be honest and just be be willing to
talk with people and reach out and
that the more you do that the more the
easier it gets to get to a place of um
true acceptance to keep moving one step
at a time so
i'm gonna message you back right after
this but thank you for being here and uh
yeah
if anyone can get through it
see you buddy
[Music]